hey guys it's Pete peppers from Candy
Crush Soda Saga tips and I'm going to do
a little how-to video for the new game
Candy Crush jelly which should be out
any day now and we'll talk about the uh
the mode where you have to beat the
queen this is a mode where we have an
opponent is actually different from any
other game that than I know of so far
and uh it's really cool can be
frustrating but it's a lot of fun um you
make a move and then she makes a move so
that you have like a literal opponent
which is pretty nice and you can see
that the goal here when we play her is
to spread more jelly or spread enough
jelly to be the queen so this is level
four this is the simplest one but we got
to spread enough to beat her so looking
over the
board you can see at the top we have a
meter our our jelly is the dark
purple and hers is the green and you can
see that right now we have 14 out of 36
so we have to spread our gel Jam or
jelly across crossed 36 squares to win
this sometimes it's the whole board
sometimes it's not it just you just have
to look at the meter but as we spread
ours you'll see the meter go up if she
spreads hers to cover ours then the
meter will go down and um you know it
can go back and forth throughout another
thing to keep in mind here and something
that's really important is when we make
specials like I'm going to do on my
first move I'm going to make a fish you
see up here it says creating a special
candy will stun the boss so now I get to
make an extra move so that's always a
good thing to do pretty much um always
uh so look for that and we can also do
it in areas that are outside of um where
our Jam is but in
general you know whenever I you know I
spread Jam just like I would in any
other one so you could see the meter one
up because I covered three more
squares she'll take her turn and if she
doesn't make a special then I get to go
so
so let's see where we're going to go now
there's nothing that's really jumping
out as a as a a real power move so I'm
just going to go ahead and set that up
over
there you can make moves on her side but
it's not usually very um very good idea
obviously because you don't want to um
spread her color if it's a situation I
don't we don't have one yet cuz they're
not close to each other but if it's a
situ situation where you're making a
match and both colors are there your
color will Co cover hers and that goes
vice versa for whenever she has it as
well so I got a couple specials over
here
um um I just need to get a couple
more the the queen is is somewhat
predictable um it can be you know she's
she you know she's simple in her choices
of
moves sometimes it can be
annoying because there's going to be
things that you're going to want her to
do but that really comes into play more
in the uh cupcake Carl one where you
have to the pufflers so here this should
probably finish things up um I'll be
able to make a couple more specials in a
row
SASS and um it says up here now since I
got triple stun you can see the um the
the sort of sparkles on the outside that
means that I get a special move which
this is going to be enough to finish it
anyways with this combo but watch it'll
make like a little
explosion in the area of that match too
so the triple
stun will always help you out and you
can see I I cover an up Square so now I
win Sugar
Crush
jous so it's pretty straightforward um
reason why I'm doing a h to is some
people B and I think you know one of the
things that happens is the very
beginning levels are really easy and
then as you get up the gets more
complicated as far as strategy
goes so I just went ahead and Skip to
level 29 this is kind of one of the
first really hard um beat the queen
levels so I'm going to load that up to
talk about some different things the
reason why this one is
hard is because both boards are separate
right now and so we have to make some
sort of a special in order to get our
Jam down like we can't we can't expand
our our color until we do that and since
the board's small and um there's a
decent amount of colors on it it's
pretty hard to set things up you know we
just don't get those easy um you know
choices and then there's the added
problem of she gets to move after us
below so anything we like try to set up
up here can be she can wipe it out just
by making a match underneath
so so like right here there's really not
a whole lot of the way of good moves um
just looking it over so I'm just going
to go ahead and move
that and then she'll make a move and
things will move around so we'll just
see
so this will be good we got a we have a
striped that we
get and we can fire that off and now
that's going to take our our Jam down to
the bottom
board and that just gives us more more
choices um she took out most of it right
away but um that's a general idea of how
you want to approach it just want to um
you know try to think ahead when you can
when you're playing the queen try to um
anticipate she'll make the simplest move
most of the time so try to anticipate
what she's going to do and then if um if
you can you know you're going to want to
play a little bit of Defense from time
to time but um I hope that's I'm not
going to make this a super long video so
I hope that gives you a general idea of
how it works remember about stunning her
by making specials and remember about
that triple stun especially on levels
that have like coils or blockers and
things um that are you know where you
have to cover the whole board that that
triple stun can really come in helpful
come in handy I should say so please
like the video if you have any questions
about how to beat the queen um leave
them in the comments make sure you
subscribe to the channel to get more um
howto with commentary videos from this
and all the other games we play and uh
hope to see you soon
thanks hey guys this is Pete Peppers
this is a candy cr jelly Saga how to for
what I think is the toughest new game
mode or level type in the game The
Cupcake Carl um game mode and um it
involves pufflers if you haven't watched
our pufflers video should check that out
to learn more about them but I'm just
going to concentrate on how we have to
go up against Carl himself so Carl is
like the queen which again if you
haven't watched
our um how to beat the queen video yet
you should probably check that out but
when we play against the queen we have
to spread Jam um more than her cover her
color up right so with cupcake Carl here
we have to actually catch more pufflers
than he does so you can see that you
catch pufflers just like you would on
any other level but the one thing to
notice here is we have a meter and we
have a total of three that we need to
get before he gets a total of three
three okay
so it doesn't necessarily mean that
there's six under here I think it
actually might mean that there's a few
more but the first first
player either us or Carl who gets the
three wins the level
so the biggest
standout in this versus mode compared to
the queen
is since we're removing
ice
and he's doing the same thing you know
we have to actually plan out so that we
don't leave a situation where he can
um you know we we knock all the ice
except for one square off and then he
can just come in and and take our our
spoils or whatever you want to say
so just like any versus level you know
you can see I got a triple stun so
that's always a good thing to do you see
the sparkling on the
outside um
I made you know as many specials as I
could so
now like say here I could I could match
these two together if I don't he might
but say here since I have the um the
super match or whatever they call it um
I should be able to free this entire
puffer here just like that so if you get
your um you know your super
match probably a good idea to do that
since we're you know we're
competing so now I'll just continue to
look for more specials I can make
and or you know where I can get this guy
out over here neither one of them looks
real
good um see if I pop the top off of here
then that'll he'll probably move but um
just really not an advantage it's really
just going to get that ready for
Carl
so you could play defense here I got 11
moves left
um and yeah I'm just going to go ahead
and do that just move remove a useless
piece of ice and sort of wait to see
what what
materializes so here I can make a fish
or I can make a a WRA and I'm going to
get an extra move go ahead and make the
WRA it moved down as you saw but I can
free this one up here so you know this
is a typical decision that you'll come
across when you're playing
um since we have to get the thing we're
going to get that first but you know
making this match would would open up a
little bit of the space but it doesn't
make a special so it doesn't stun Carl
and he gets to move next so you
definitely want to go for free and
Puffer that you can see right there
rather than
um you know any other kind of move um
that would take you away from taking the
lead so here we have one there may be
there may be two here actually there are
two here so the main thing we want to do
is not let
him get two before we get one more
so none of these moves are that great
I'm just going to go ahead and drop this
to change things up a little bit that's
going to give him a pretty
good go to make a
special but luckily he's not that smart
and he decided to do that I can um can
make this fish and collect the last one
at the same time and that's pretty much
how it works so this is this the
simplest of all the cupcake Carl levels
these get really tough later
on so some general tips you want to keep
in mind are like just what try to
anticipate what he's going to do and um
there's a lot of frustration with that
more so than the queen because the Queen
the queen not being good at
making you know like um moves where they
have a you know like where they're
planning for their next move is is
helpful because you're just spreading
Jam but with Carl sometimes it's hard to
anticipate what you know it's hard to
set up something in the
future because even though you know the
to a human opponent it might be a really
obvious thing that he should do he's
going to still pick like the simplest
one so he can kind of like you know at
least for me he's frustrated me on on
several
different situations where I was just
like how would he you know a real person
would never make that move or whatever
so it can be it can be tough but
um as long as you're sord thinking ahead
you know you're going to play better
than he does but you know just kind of
kind of try to take into into account
like what he might
do based on his level of play if that
makes sense and you know don't try to
overthink it too much if you get if you
end up getting um beat by him a couple
times on road just hang in there check
out one of our check out our video of
how we did it and uh most of the time
you'll be able to beat him before too
long so I don't want to stretch this
into a really long video I'll go ahead
and and cut it off if you got any
questions about Carl or or any of the
other game modes you know leave a
question in the comments um hopefully
you'll like this video if you found it
helpful and you'll subscribe to my
channel um you know we make the best
how-to commentary videos and we keep up
to date with a lot of popular games so
that you can uh get your level videos as
soon as they are
released so definitely subscribe so you
can keep up to date with things and um
I'll see you
soon
hey guys be Peppers here and making a
how video for licorice Larry he's the
um he's the bunny looking character here
who is the boss of the monklings levels
and um he's the you know the counterpart
of the queen and cupcake Carl he's our
third villain so
far and he's probably one of the easier
ones to understand I guess um if you
don't really have a good idea of how the
monklings work make sure you check out
our monklings video I'll leave a link at
the top here so that you can check that
out but um Larry does the same thing we
do he tries to hatch his
monklings by collecting the blue light
blue or cyan
candies and our job is
to collect black DARS with the orange so
you can see at the top we have a meter
we we have to beat him to five and 20
moves we have to collect five before he
collects five or we run out to move
so we're going to want to drop our drop
our moning down and
then we don't really have to block as
much as say like when we're playing the
queen
um especially not in this particular
level but um it is something that that
will come in strategy wise at different
times now there's a couple
things that
um you know that help that I didn't
really it took a it took a while to you
know figure out everything as far as it
goes as there he goes but um one
thing that wasn't immediate appar
immediately apparent was is that
um
when when we make matches with blue as I
did right there those don't count
towards his collection and vice versa so
like
whenever you might see him do something
like set off a color bomb and you know
take out all the orange you would think
oh that's a good thing I'm collecting
orange but if you watch you won't be
getting any
so it can actually be a little bit
frustrating at times whenever
he he does um instead of like doing what
you think he might do like he actually
blocks instead like that I think that's
probably the most frustrating thing like
Carl's
frustrating um for different reasons and
um definitely the queen can be
frustrating for different reasons but in
particular with um
Larry when he blocks it's kind of really
annoying because
it just seems like sometimes he's not
trying to win he's
um he's just trying to stop us from
winning which is all he really has to do
when you think about it so the little
pop-up tell me have to collect more than
he does I did collect one of his there
um that's not always a good idea but I
also got another one of mine on board
and I'm still ahead so that's something
that you're just going to want to um you
know decide on the Fly making you know
stun moves are the same here as they are
with the other two so you do want to
make those in my opinion pretty often
but um a couple things to keep in mind
there is that stun moves that collect
your oranges are better than ones that
don't and then when we use our super
stun move after we do three which I'm
not going to be able to do here it
doesn't look like um we want to we want
to plan it out where we don't you know
where we actually Advance our our mon
clings if we
can so yeah like I said I couldn't make
another one there so it's just the way
that worked
out but
um this is a pretty easy level so
they're not really in trouble here we
have uh four out and about
and all we really need to do now is um
collect one
more and then we can drop them all
down and that'll be
that not a whole lot going on here
that's uh you know strategically
important just sort
of just sort of uh kind of a the board
is kind of tightened up right now
so going go ahead and collect these this
should be enough to bring the last one
on the
board and now we'll have four moves and
we'll probably want to make some sort of
special to get the rest of these
down let's
see we could continue to make uh
monklings as you know if we collect more
oranges we don't really need to on this
particular
board this will be good it'll get rid of
two of them for us and give us a
stun
and then we can finish it off right here
with the purple
candies so you see there it didn't
really make a big difference um how many
he
had you know um there like I said
there's other boards where that will all
right so this is 142 and this one is one
where
where we do actually have to be really
conscious of what he's doing and how and
and um try to stop him from dropping his
down
first in the beginning we're going to
start out pretty much the say we need to
get rid of these blockers
um so making specials and getting stuns
are good but it's also kind of tight
until we get rid of some of this stuff
so just try to find the the best mov
first making Stripes is always pretty
good for whenever the um for whenever
the monklings actually get on the board
so it's really never a bad thing to do
we do want to move ours down as fast as
we can too since there's only one orange
Square here so you know we want to we
want to make sure it's clear for the
next one to come out right away so we
don't lose any time when we're
collecting nice to get
Cascades
his side's kind of all smashed up right
now
so can kind of just focus on our
side he just did a little blocking
[Music]
there
that's a good combo for
us so we have three and you can see he
already had two so you can see that it's
a little more you know it's a little
more
um since these fill up pretty fast and
you get them on the board pretty fast
it's it's a definite possibility that we
could if we're not paying attention to
what he's doing that he could actually
get his on the board too fast and we
would lose like where he's not just
playing to um stop us but he could
actually
win think we're pretty good shape though
we got both of them on the board already
he still only has three so long as we
don't make any major mistakes here we
should be
good this will be helpful if he doesn't
mess it
up let's
see
every once in a while he'll have he
he'll end up helping us some
because what you know his side of the
board's messed
up it doesn't it doesn't happen as much
as like when you're playing Carl though
for
sure yeah so this is a mess down here
let's see if we
can
he kind of messed up there I don't know
if you noticed that
but all right
so just need to get this off and we got
three moves
so what can we do here bottom is just is
just a mess
all right so two moves this will work as
long as he doesn't mess it up for
us there we go so you know Larry he's
pretty cool he's a little different than
the other bosses but there's same basic
concept just have to approach his levels
a little
different always you know kind of figure
out how many
oranges it takes to fill it up fill up
your meter see how many how fast they're
coming out try to figure out in the
beginning whether you're trying to um
you know actively block him and and
watch out like take his colors off the
board and stuff like that and then just
um you know plan accordingly like I said
hopefully this will help and you'll
um give it a like if you found it
helpful and subscribe to my channel to
get access to all the latest how-to
videos and level videos as soon as they
come out
thanks